ja heute mal wieder ein whatsapp
themenvorschlag vielen dank ihr seid der
hammer es geht um die kuriosesten und
krassesten zahlen des weltraums wir
klären fragen wie gibt es mehr
sandkörner auf der erde oder mehr sterne
im universum auf welchem planeten ist
die windstärke mit 1600 kilometern pro
stunde am stärksten und auf welchem
planeten sind wir menschen am
leichtesten also angeber wissen zum
staunen jetzt bei klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen und wie ihr
zu whatsapp kommt dass der vater am ende
des videos
platz sieben wie groß ist das universum
wie kurs ist es die antwort niemand weiß
es ja tut mir leid da fängt schon mal
schlechter aber ich will euch jetzt
nicht dumm sterben lassen einig ist es
ganz logisch das universum ist ja 13,8
milliarden jahre alt da sicher nicht
schneller als mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
fortbewegen kann müsste es einen
maximalen durchmesser von 27,6
milliarden haben aber das stimmt auch
nicht denn es gibt etwas das sie
schneller als licht fortbewegen kann ja
hat denn der krachten die ganze zeit
gelogen nein beides ist richtig wie kann
das sein
ja das was sich schneller bewegt als
licht ist eigentlich nicht etwas
es ist der raum selbst das universum
dehnt sich nämlich schneller als mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit aus wenn wir was
berücksichtigen dann wissen wir
zumindest eines wie weit wir in jede
richtung blicken können und das sind
46,6 milliarden lichtjahre also das
universum dass wir sehen können hat
einen durchmesser von 93,2 milliarden
lichtjahren ob allerdings dahinter noch
etwas ist das wissen wir leider nicht
platz 6 der saturn besteht zu 96 prozent
aus wasserstoff vielleicht wissen einige
von euch dass der saturn ein gasplanet
ist und bis auf vier prozent aus
wasserstoff besteht er hat eine so
geringe mittlere dichte dass er wohlauf
wasser schwimmen würde er ist der
äußerste planet mit dem bloßen auge
sichtbar und war den menschen deswegen
schon vor der erfindung des fernrohrs
bekannt zudem ist der saturn auch der
planet mit dem krassesten wind die
windstärken in seiner atmosphäre
erreichen bis zu 1600 kilometern pro
stunde
außerdem ist der saturn etwa neuneinhalb
war so weit von der sonne entfernt wie
die erde und somit braucht er für einen
orbit um die sonne extrem lang eine
umkreisung der sonne auf dem rad uhren
dauert 30 jahre auf der erde
platz fünf wie viele sterne gibt es
eigentlich im weltall mehr als
sandkörner auf der erde weil man noch
nicht einmal weiß wie groß das universum
ist weiß man auch nicht ganz sicher wie
viele sterne es tatsächlich da draußen
gibt aber es gibt schätzungen nach denen
es eine quad region sterne sind also
eine eins mit 24 0
vor allem wenn man das mit der anzahl
der geschätzten sandkörner auf der erde
vergleicht eine studie kommt nämlich auf
eine zahl von nur sie
millionen und 500 milliarden lächerlich
also im vergleich zu den sternen und es
ist ja zu wenig sand hier auf der erde
ist droht ja eine weltweite sand krise
platz vier ein tag auf der venus dauert
länger als ein venus ja jetzt wird es
ein bisschen komplizierter 234 erdentage
dauert einen tag auf der venus und ist
damit tatsächlich länger als ein venus
ja dass nur 225 tage dauert aber wie
kann das sein
erst einmal unterscheidet sich die venus
gar nicht so sehr von der erde sie ist
zwar ein bisschen kleiner hat aber eine
ähnliche dichte und eine etwas kürzere
umlaufzeit um die sonne
doch ihre oberfläche ist extrem heiß mit
bis zu 500 grad celsius heiß genug um
sogar blight schmelzen zu lassen jetzt
zurück zur eigentlichen frage sondern 25
tage beträgt die mittlere umlaufzeit der
venus um die sonne
doch die eigenen rotation um die eigene
achse die dauert länger nämlich 234 er
tage und so kommt es dass ein tag auf
der venus ein bisschen länger dauert als
ein jahr ein kleiner fun fact nach oben
drauf die eigene rotation der venus
läuft degen setzt sich zu den meisten
anderen planeten im sonnensystem und auf
der 3 zwischen erde und mond ist sehr
viel platz auch wenn der mond in super
vollmondnächten wie am neujahrstag 2018
so hell und groß wirkt der trabant ist
doch eine ganze ecke von der erde
entfernt zu diesem zeitpunkt
beispielsweise 359 1000 kilometer aber
der abstand marie irrt wenn der mond auf
seiner elliptischen bahn die maximale
distanz erreicht ist der 400 5000
kilometer von der erde entfernt und dann
würden tatsächlich alle anderen acht
planeten unseres sonnensystems zwischen
mond und erde passen
das ist echt nicht ohne diese strecke
wenn man sie mit einem normalen flugzeug
zurücklegen würde wenn es ginge bräuchte
man mit zwischenlandung und tankstopps
ganze 20 tage knappe zwei tage dauert es
dagegen lediglich die erde am äquator zu
umrunden platz zwei fußabdrücke auf dem
mond halten sich ewig vielleicht wisst
ihr ja auf dem mond gibt es kein wetter
und das heißt im mondstaub sind immer
noch die fußspuren von neil armstrong
und buzz aldrin zu finden sie könnten
quasi einfach nur mal kurz um die ecke
verschwunden sein und gleich wieder
auftauchen ja anders als hier auf der
erde werden spuren auf dem mond weder
von wind noch warmwasser verwischt sie
halten sich millionen von jahren nur ein
mitglied der zufällig genau an diese
stelle an dieser stelle ein trifft der
könnte sie verschwinden lassen aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist groß dass ihre
fußabdrücke unsere zivilisation
überdauern und meine absolute
lieblingsstadt diät einfach mal ab auf
dem mars wir berichten ja immer wieder
mal über den mars denn viele experten
als erdähnliche zeichnen eines ist dort
aber sicher ganz anders als auf der erde
unser körpergewicht nämlich und das hat
mit der schwerkraft zu tun die uns zur
oberfläche hin zieht das wissen wir aber
noch aus dem physikunterricht die größer
die masse eines objekts umso größer ist
auch die gravitation waren auf dem
saturn und jupiter die beschleunigung
also bei uns heißt das der
erdbeschleunigung 9,81 meter pro sekunde
im quadrat höher ist als auf der erde
wegen der dort viel mehr als hier einen
70 kilogramm schwerer mensch würde auf
dem jupiter 175 gramm wiegen anders
dagegen auf dem mars wenn man auf der
erde also 70 kilogramm wien sind es auf
dem mars nur noch drei achtel davon also
gute 26 kilogramm baby ich bin auf dem
mars ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum
thema mars besiedlung zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfährt er von mir vor allen andern vom
neuesten video täglich garantiert ihr
könnt dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion vom tricks und mitmachen und
mir themen vorschlagen wie hier zum
beispiel oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum
passiert und zur begrüßung gibt es noch
ein kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der glocke vergessen und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
1000 raketen zum mars ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran